واعزائي المشاهدين هذه صور حصريه لقناه
العربيه من قاعده جبل شركاب شمال ام درمان
بعد سيطره الجيش السوداني على هذه القاعده
العربيه هي اول قناه تدخل الى هذه القاعده
بالطبع شمال ام درمان كان شهد قتالا عنيفا
بين قوات الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع هذه المشاهد من داخل قاعده جبل
شركاب في شمال ام درمان بعد ان تمكن الجيش
من السيطره على هذه القاعده كما تردنا في
هذه الصور اذا الجيش السوداني في مشاهد
خاصه وحصريه لقناه العربيه يسيطر على
قاعده جبل سركاب شمال
ام درمان بالطبع شمال ام درمان حتى غرب ام
درمان كان شهد معارك عنيفه بين الجيش
السوداني والقوات الدعم السريع في محاوله
من انقلاء الطرفين للسيطره على المرافق
والمواقع الاستراتيجيه في العاصمه
السودانيه
الخرطوم لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات